nur danach schmecken wow warum lall ich
so ich glaube du übernimmst ab sofort
die Moderationen
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in den Sallys
Welt heute gibt es Ferrero Rocher
Cupcakes nein ich meine natürlich
Cookies
[Applaus]
okay
[Gelächter]
heute geht es zur Cookies wir brauchen
dafür keine verloren aber die sollen ja
schmecken wie Ferrero Rocher außen
knackig Schokolade ich haselnussig und
innen ein Softair Kern das probieren wir
und zwar sind hier die Zutaten schon
aufgelistet oder aufgereiht ich habe sie
hier abgewogen
was Ihr dafür nicht braucht sind Ferrero
Rocher nur danach schmecken warum lalig
so ich glaube du übernimmst ab sofort
die Moderationen
sowieso nicht mehr viel ich meine wie
groß bist du jetzt
ich bin 1,75
ich meine sie hat ja schon meine beste
Freundin überholt denkst du das sind 20
Zentimeter
frag mal lieber Community ich bin nicht
so gut im Abschätzen von 20 Cent
genau ich sag mal kurz die Zutaten dafür
verwenden wir 110 Gramm weiche Butter 50
g weißen Zucker 120g braunen Zucker
etwas Salz und Vanilleextrakt ein Ei 150
g Mehl plus Backpulver oder ihr
verwendet mein backmehl 25 g Kakao 50 g
gemahlene Haselnüsse und zum Füllen
verwende ich 160 g Nutella oder eine
andere Nuss Nougat Creme 70g gehackte
Haselnüsse und 30 g Schokodrops das war
super aber warte lassen wir mal gucken
nee ich glaube du bist ein bisschen
kleiner als 155 weil
53 ja genau so ungefähr so zwei drei
Zentimeter nach unten
passt schon aber du bist schon so groß
wie Nadja
und ich habe zum gleichen Tag Geburtstag
meiner besten Freundin zur Welt und
Samiras beste Freundin kam an meinem
Geburtstag so weit
verkauft am 17.02 beginnt die neue
Staffel Let's Dance und ich tanze dieses
Mal auch mit ich bin richtig aufgeregt
ich freue mich total und ich hoffe ihr
seid alle mit dabei ab dem 17.02 jeden
Freitag live im Fernsehen da muss
natürlich auch angerufen werden und ich
zähle auf ihre Stimmen und ich freue
mich jetzt schon sehr ein bisschen tanzt
sich noch in meiner Küche aber bald
tanzt sich bei Let's Dance
jetzt können wir Murat rufen mit seinem
Kärcher
[Musik]
besser hätte es nicht laufen können oder
okay Sammy dann darfst du jetzt hier
eigentlich alle Zutaten außer Nutella
Haselnüsse und Schokodrops in die
Rührschüssel geben ihr könnt euch gerne
ein bisschen leiser machen hier ist das
erste deutsche Fernsehen mit der
Tagesschau
ihr könnt sich gerne ein bisschen
leichter machen und die
Butter mit dem Zucker und dem anderen
Zucker verrühren aber eigentlich ist es
so ein All in One Tag man braucht bei
Cookies nicht vorher die Sachen
verrühren Haut einfach alles rein
verrührt zusammen und es soll ein
schöner cremiger Teig entstehen
noch haben wir keine
keine Themen die uns jetzt belasten
deswegen
und beim braunen Zucker ist oft so da
ist so klumpig und der zieht
Feuchtigkeit aber wenn ihr da eine ganze
Schüssel voll braune Zucker habt dann
könnt ihr das auch mal kurz in die
Mikrowelle stellen kurz die Mikrowelle
anmachen und dann entweicht die
Flüssigkeit und die Feuchtigkeit und
dann ist der braune Zucker wieder schön
so wie er eben gehört
aber es passt da nicht so zu Rocher ja
okay alle Zutaten rein
[Musik]
und ich arbeite für dich und entwickeln
neue Produkte und neue Rezepte okay
ich glaube
wir brauchen noch ein Ei für dieses
Rezept glaube ich auch wir nehmen noch
ein Eis
wie sage ich da das war mein Grundrezept
und dann habe ich auch noch Haselnüsse
rein und deswegen ich habe mir gedacht
wir brauchen vielleicht eins aber ich
dachte mir so kommen wir probieren
ja da ist schon gut aber ein bisschen
brauchen wir schon noch okay
also so sieht er jetzt perfekt aus nicht
zu weich nicht zu fest
richtig gut okay stellen wir den kurz
zur Seite mit der Nuss nougat-masse
haben wir schon folgendes gemacht wenn
sie nur snougat-masse mit einem kleinen
Eisportionierer schon portioniert auf
einer Dauerbackfolie und eingefroren
damit das Ganze so kleine schokobällchen
sind die gleich fest sind denn dann ist
das Befüllen mit dem Cookie Teig ein
bisschen einfacher okay
und jetzt nehmt ihr euch einen mittleren
Eisportionierer
und könnt jetzt hier in kleine Teigmenge
drauf geben und am besten auch mit etwas
Abstand
Mausi zwei stadtteig ist knapp Mama hat
nie einen Stress
okay
gut hier sind sie schon ein bisschen
eingefroren es geht auch wirklich
richtig schnell ich hatte die jetzt
gerade mal 10 15 Minuten drin ähm lass
uns eine Palette nehmen
und dann
können wir nämlich hier den Teig einmal
kurz flach drücken aber nicht so weit
weil wir wollen später keinen
riesengroßen Cookie dazu dünn ist
sondern nur so eine kleine Fläche
schaffen und hier kommt dann eine
nuss-nougat-füllung rein
und dann decken wir das Ganze gleich ab
[Musik]
und dann kommt noch mal eine Portion
Teig obendrauf mit dem Eisportionierer
und dann schön diese Nuss nougat-masse
da rennen verschließen okay da muss man
einfach ein bisschen drauf achten dass
eben keine Nuss Nougat Creme nach
draußen kommen damit es nicht ausläuft
[Musik]
es fehlt wahrscheinlich genau der
Nachteil aber das macht nichts
dann den Rest auch nachschen da komm
dafür dürfte immer die fertigen Kuchen
und Torten naschen aber trotzdem der
Ruhetag ist mal am besten ja das stimmt
okay und damit das Ganze jetzt aber auch
nach dem Backen aussieht wie so Ferrero
Rocher kommen da natürlich noch die
gehackten Haselnüsse drauf
und ein paar Schokodrops
und dann dürft ihr gerne schon mal den
ofen vorheizen auf 180 Grad Heißluft da
kann ich nämlich beide Bleche dann
gleichzeitig packen willst du noch
helfen oder naschen
ist selber machen
ich weiß schon warum ich immer alleine
die zerlaufen jetzt ein bisschen im Ofen
werden richtig schön und nach dem Backen
Stelle Sie einfach hier draußen auf die
Arbeitsfläche und rührt sie erstmal
nicht an denn sie sind dann noch
zerbrechlich also wir lassen sie dann
erstmal ganz abkühlen und
dazwischenräumen wir auch oder manche
kann man da noch so ein bisschen
andrücken und dann sind sie nach dem
Backen wirklich rundherum wunderschöner
hoffentlich
das Anton das Michelle das Chantal des
seneb und wie hieß der noch mal
okay dann heißt nämlich
jetzt sind die Cookies gebacken und die
sehen echt schön aus oder und das ganze
Haus riecht nach Cookies und nach dem
Abkühlen kann man sie auch wirklich
wunderbar vom Blech runter nehmen okay
wir teilen
und eins zwei drei
der Keks hat sich prozentual so verteilt
wie wir zwei aufgeteilt sind du hast den
kleinen größeren weil ich größer bin
aber du kriegst mehr da ist so ein
richtig lecker saftiger Schoko Kern
guckt mal
hatte ich dich schon mal mit in so einem
Fernsehstudio wo gekocht wird nee die
haben immer so einen anklatsche und
einen der immer anfängt mit mmh oder
bevor so eine Aufzeichnung ist kriegt
man immer die nach wenn einer macht und
dann machen alle mitmachen den
Fernsehsendung immer alle mit mhmm oh oh
oh
okay probieren wir jetzt
[Musik]
also ich fand es nicht lustig und ich
habe auch nicht gelacht ich habe mir
schon gedacht dass der gut wird aber
dass der so gut wird
wie flüssig ist bitte dieser Kern
ja ich glaube wir backen gleich noch
eine Portion
wenn ich das Rezept nachmachen wollt und
ihr wollt das glaubst du ihr wollt
dieses Rezept nachmachen dann schaut auf
sallys-blog.de vorbei oder in meiner App
da könnt ihr nämlich euch die App
einfach kostenlos runterladen egal ob
iPhone Samsung oder welches Gerät auch
immer
die App ist kostenlos und ihr findet
alle Rezepte ihr könnt sie da dann
direkt hochrechnen also statt zehn
Cookies könnt ihr dann direkt auf 20
klicken oder noch mehr und könnt euch
eine Einkaufsliste erstellen und dann
eben eure Rezepte nachmachen so wie Ihr
möchtet viel Spaß dabei bis zum nächsten
Mal und wir genießen jetzt unsere
Cookies
richtig gut